mind your decisions i'm presh talwalkar
in a rectangle two line segments are
drawn dividing the rectangle into four
regions
three of the regions have areas of one
three and four
what is the area of the fourth region
this diagram is not drawn to scale
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we'll get started by focusing on these
two triangles
these two angles are equal to each other
because they're vertical angles
next these two angles are equal to each
other because they're alternate interior
angles
this is because opposite sides of a
rectangle are parallel to each other
consequently these two triangles have
two equal angles which means all three
angles are equal and these triangles are
similar
as their areas are in a ratio of four to
one their sides will be in a ratio of
two to one that's because the area is
proportional to side length squared
suppose the top triangle has a side
length of a
its corresponding side length in the
bottom triangle must be 2a
if the top triangle has a height of h
then the bottom triangle will have a
height of two h
consider the area of the top triangle
it'll be a times h all over two
that'll be equal to one
this means a h is equal to two
now go back to the rectangle
we can solve for one of its side lengths
it'll be equal to h plus two h
therefore this side length will be three
h
the other side length is 2a
therefore the area of this entire
rectangle will be 2a multiplied by 3h
which is equal to 6ah
since ah is equal to 2 6ah will be equal
to 12.
we can then solve the problem quite
easily
three of the areas in the rectangle are
1 3 and 4.
that means the last area will be 12
minus 1 minus 3 minus 4 and that's equal
to four
and that's the missing area
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]